ah
[Música]
i
a pesar de ser el país de américa latina
que mayor porcentaje de su población ha
vacunado casi un 70 con una dosis y más
del 52 por ciento de la población
objetivo con 2 dosis si les sigue
experimentando en la última semana una
tasa sostenida en el número de contagios
reportados a diario el viernes se
reportó la segunda cifra más alta de
toda la pandemia casi 8 mil 700 casos a
la que siguió al día siguiente la
tercera cifra más alta de toda la
pandemia casi 8.500 muy por encima de
las cifras de la primera ola el ministro
de salud enrique parís señala que el 86
por ciento de las personas que están en
las unidades de cuidados intensivos no
han completado su esquema de inoculación
el llamado es acudir a vacunarse y para
eso los vacunatorios abren ahora también
los fines de semana mientras continúa en
el país la polémica por el pase de
movilidad que otorga el gobierno y que
entró en vigor esta semana y permite
transitar a los inoculados en zonas de
cuarentena y también entre región en
regiones el colegio médico señala que no
era el momento para este tipo de señales
mientras la ocupación hospitalaria se
mantiene en un preocupante 96%
[Música]
españa es el sexto país europeo más
avanzado en el proceso de vacunación el
20 por ciento del total de la población
ya está inmunizada con la vacuna
completa el 40 por ciento más de 18
millones de personas ha recibido a lo
menos una vacuna españa ha logrado
obtener un incremento medio mensual en
el ritmo de vacunación del 63 por ciento
desde que empezó el proceso hace 5 meses
esta semana llegarán 46 millones de
dosis de viales un nuevo récord que
permitirá iniciar la vacunación de las
personas entre 40 y 49 años la nueva
fase prevista para junio españa espera
ahora alcanzar su objetivo llegar a el
70% de la población inmunizada al final
del verano pero ya podemos ver los
resultados los fallecimientos caen un 85
por ciento respecto a febrero
[Música]
las autoridades sanitarias israelíes han
anunciado que a partir del 31 de mayo no
renovarán las restricciones del
coronavirus en el país esto quiere decir
que a partir del 1 de junio los
israelíes podrán además de pasearse al
aire libre sin mascarilla cosa que ya
hace la mayoría desde hace más de un mes
podrán reunirse ahora en interiores más
de 20 personas en exterior más de 100 y
el sistema de pasaporte verde que
distinguía entre inoculados y no
inoculados también pasa a formar parte
del pasado las mascarillas en interior
en lugares públicos todavía sigue
estando en vigor y sin embargo parece
que no por mucho tiempo se está
revisando la medida ya que la mayor
parte de los médicos indica que tal vez
también ésta sea innecesaria y en las
próximas dos semanas llegarán a una
conclusión ahora israel se enfrenta con
dos retos en realidad la entrada en el a
por el aeropuerto de otras cepas o de
más personas contagiadas y por eso las
medidas del aeropuerto son bastante
draconianas y cambian casi cada día y
también el dilema de los niños de esos 9
millones de habitantes israelíes
dos millones son niños y no son
candidatos todavía a ser vacunados
[Música]